[Music]
so unlike many of you here I am NOT
technology savvy person however I'm just
very practical person so today I simply
would like to share one of the features
I found very useful and practical that
is campus matters okay so builders are
full-time to say don't even try to build
a house without blueprints okay so
blueprints the general definition of it
is a set of construction or working
drawings that define all the
constructions pax opens a residential
house such as dimensions materials
layouts insulation methods and
techniques okay so in the same context I
think teaching and learning modules
means detailed lesson plans that
presents assessment assignments projects
or homework learning activities
presentations resources even timeline
and expected or final outcomes so
basically you can put every ingredients
into these campus matters about your
course therefore I think canvas modules
really function as blueprints of your
course curriculum that you see here you
can organize your materials by the each
each category so even resources you can
put all course resources in here and
this is the big categories you can
organize your course content by unit and
time or both
so each big categories can have more
detailed ingredients so you can put as I
said here assignment like a
presentations or test creatures in
everything
so again why do I use campus matters I
said it's easy to use and it's a clear
communication tool communication tool
between me and my students and my
colleagues and my teaching fellows
especially for multi section and team
teaching setting also this is great tool
for course organized so I'm a course
head and coordinator of the program so
through these campus modules I can
really keep curricular consistency and
pedagogical alignment and also a great
tool for teacher training my TFS and
often times they call what do I teach
and how do I teach and I clearly
directed them to these campus modules so
through these canvas modules again I can
keep my course very transparent to my
students and colleagues and Teaching
Fellows so after all these campus the
modules can function as your course
portfolio so these are the frequently
asked questions I get I'm sure you guys
add these kind of questions from used
students for Teaching Fellows or
colleagues so where should I upload my
assignments students still ask the
questions surprisingly some of the
students don't even read the course
syllabus onto the end of semester and
what should I cover next weekly in
Section X tips can ask these questions
and what do you teach in this course
well oftentimes it's your colleagues ask
you but you can answer by say I teach
very well and I do lot of different
stuff in my class that's just simply
visualize what you do with your students
in the course through canvas matters and
these questions go on and on and on so
now you know my answer is you can answer
for me through canvas
badges that is correct yes so this is
great tool and very easy to utilize so
please use them as much as possible and
I get great our support from Christine
and kimberlyn or canvas colleagues
that's it how many of you use canvas
modules huh see you can add some
anecdote the term forget that you're
using the modules I know this is
something that I struggle with like I
have to tell my students repeatedly over
and over again oh where is this resource
it's in the modules so big image that I
clearly say everything is in the majors
and then I enforce them you know every
day did you check campus about yours and
then first week or so they organ settled
yeah if you sign like for example for
mine I organize everything by chapters
so they will look for that particular
item in modules in that chapter but
otherwise you're right I mean I can't
keep my quizzes and quizzes because
nobody will find them or else they will
take the wrong one of course we know
that problem but the linear organization
beat by week I highly recommend
organizing either on calendar basis like
how your syllabus runs week 1 week 2 or
in our case is by chapter another option
is to use pages and on the first page
you will just have a link to the right
modules and that that way they won't be
confused
any other questions or comments all
right
[Applause]
[Music]